what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing on with our
discussion about Dark Knights medal we
pick up with part three and this is
really cool because what this does is it
gives us the origin of the Dark
multiverse and is really really
interesting plus it's also like Superman
vs the Dark Knights but remember the
whole idea of Dark Knight's metal is as
kind of like this worst case scenario in
a lot of waste well we're not
necessarily given a time frame of
exactly when Dark Knight's metal happens
that is to say where it happens in
relation to like two Justice League or
something like that
for the most part it kind of focuses on
the individual characters solo series in
terms of placements about when different
things happen you know see Superman
numbers such and such see Action Comics
whatever the whole idea is that were a
lot of events that have been written and
like Justice League so far things like
that are really kind of dark and Robby
this takes it to a whole new level
because in the last videos we talked
about how Batman was the key that the
idea here was that there were these
metals that existed inside the DC
Universe and originally they were just
believed to have just been metals that
were powerful for whatever reason in
metal promethium died in ECM different
things like that but what does story
revealed is that all those metals
basically served as a kind of proving
material in the sense that when Batman
was doused in all those metals it
basically allowed the evil Batman from
the dark multiverse to enter the
positive multiverse of DC and for Batman
to be sent to the dark multiverse it
basically opened a gateway and so the
whole idea here the whole concept is
what's the next step if the goal is to
bring darkness into the positive
multiverse to basically initiate the
plan of Barbados to bring everything
crashing down then there has to be an
energy source for this and the cool
thing is that it was always believed to
be Batman that's everything we've seen
so far and so what this does is it
initially picks up in Smallville Kansas
which is cool because we've got Superboy
we've got Damian Wayne and they're just
kind of putting on a concert for like
Louis and Wonder Woman and Batman and
Superman you know and it's cool because
they're waiting on all the other
superheroes to get there Bruce goes on
this whole diatribe about hey guys look
after this war we've won against
Barbados I'm so glad that we managed to
pull this off and is interesting because
this is the aftermath for Dark Knight's
metal and so with this battle having
been one against Barbados with the Dark
Knight's having been defeated life
basically goes back to its own place it
goes back to regularity and this is cool
because this is one of the things you
don't really see from Snyder you don't
really see the sort of peacetime
situation instead for the most part you
see the conflict situation that is until
Batman starts bleeding out of his chest
in the form of a bat and and this starts
freaking people out
because in these moments when Bruce
Wayne basically starts to die he simply
just says carpe diem and then he's gone
in his place comes Barbados and Barbados
just kind of emerges and Superman's kind
of in shock and awe because in his mind
they won the conflict it was all done it
was over in Barbados simply says that's
because I let you believe that every
road you take it always leads to me it
always leads to darkness and that's the
cool thing because when the dark nights
start showing up and they start you know
just eliminating like Lois Lane and
Wonder Woman and all these different
characters Superman's just sort of
forced to sit there and witness it and
so what ends up happening is he
basically comes to and what we end up
finding out is that Superman and Wonder
Woman much like Batman are forced to
relive these recurring dreams keep in
mind when Batman was taken to the Dark
multiverse when he was forced to switch
places with the Dark Knight's what this
meant was that within the Dark
multiverse he was hooked up to a machine
of sorts and what this did is it
basically forced him to disappearance
all these terrible universes that exist
out there all these terrible realities
where everything this bad has basically
happened with Superman and Lois Lane
it's much in the same vein remember when
Batman was first taken Superman and Lois
Lane were there and they were basically
captured in defeat of our barbato's who
was a single touch is all it took to
take them both down
that was the immense power that Barbados
had but more so than that Superman
comments to Wonder Woman that he's
basically experienced this time and time
again he's tried to topple Barbados and
every single time he's failed he's
fought alongside the Joker and Lex
Luthor he's fought alongside mr. miracle
and Orion he's fought alongside all
these different characters in the DC
Universe and every time he goes against
Barbados he loses and the reason for
that is because he was hooked up to this
machine he was experiencing basically a
series of dream states but with him
being yanked back to reality at this
moment the question becomes why do we do
what's going on what's been happening in
the time that we've been gone it's been
7 days the world's basically gone to
pieces over the course of these 7 days
we learned from the Devastator story for
example that he basically spread the
entire doomsday virus to everybody in
Metropolis and essentially decided
turning them all into your doomsday so
they're just kind of walking around and
they're sort of mindless beings Superman
learns that you know Jonathan Kent's
fine Lois Lane has been transformed
these are the kind of things that go on
is basically this idea that everything's
going to pot the issue is that once he's
told that Barbados resides within Gotham
City he immediately heads there to try
to take Barbados out and this is injured
because this is not usually something
that we see when it comes to the
character of Superman Superman is pretty
hardcore and when it comes to his family
you know will be tied the poor soul who
walks up in harm's Jonathan Kent and
Lois Lane because they'll have to face
the full unbridled wrath of Superman
but for the most part he's still pretty
intelligent this moment right here where
he just sort of flies off into the
conflict
it's very indicative of like the new 52
Superman young headstrong inexperienced
that Superman is emotional right now
feeling as though the world has been
destroyed or at least is being laid
waste to by all these different
iterations of these evil Batman these
Dark Knight's all spearheaded by
Barbados and so as soon as he gets over
to where Barbados is where it gets
relatively close he immediately picks up
on what he believes to be Bruce Wayne
and that is one of the coolest aspects
of the Dark Knight's because remember
these are just different versions of
Bruce Wayne from the Dark multiverse as
far as Superman is concerned they are
Bruce Wayne but the first person he
encounters is Devastator Batman who just
wrecked Superman immediately just like
knocks him to the ground and one hit
after that it's the Batman who lasts now
keep in mind
Devastator Batman is basically doomsday
Batman what would happen if Batman was
infected with the doomsday virus the
Batman who lives is a lot more
methodical he's not really a fighter so
much as he's a manipulator a planner and
a schemer and so in that regard instead
of just showing up and just beating up
you know Superman so on and so forth he
for the most part lets Devastator Batman
do all the heavy lifting for the
character of the Batman who lost it's a
psychological war it's mind games it's
messing with Superman but one of the big
things he does is he actually spills the
beans on the nature of the dark
multiverse and this is something that we
didn't know before all we knew is that
the Dark multiverse was just there that
it was basically like two sides of the
same coin what the Batman who laughed
says is that the Dark multiverse has
existed so long as there have been
sentient beings when the first being had
their first nightmare the Dark
multiverse began to take shape
the Dark multiverse is nothing more than
just the worst fears of different beings
that have all just come to life that's
why there's an infinite number of worlds
in the dark multiverse because there's
an infinite number of fears and
nightmares that people could possibly
experience the dark nights represent
only one facet they represent the fears
of Batman they represent the idea of
Batman being terrified of becoming
doomsday they represent the idea of
Batman being terrified emerging with a
flash and becoming a villain these are
all the things that Batman is terrified
of all the fears or all the nightmares
he's ever had
one of the things that the Batman who
laughs says is in every single universe
that we're in in every single reality
that happens Batman sometimes maybe he
kills a Justice League sometimes he
doesn't but he always kills you and so
the idea that the Batman who lasts
raises is maybe it's just a desire of
Batman to destroy you to take you out
but because it's predicated and rooted
in fear means that it comes to fruition
in the dark multiverse and that's cool
because it basically brings two rays to
realization this idea if the Dark
Knight's represent one facet of the dark
multiverse and they're only confined to
some of the worst fears of Batman what
are the worst fears of Superman what are
the worst fears of Wonder Woman of the
Green Lantern Hal Jordan this is
basically Scott Snyder drawing giant
purple letters in a comic book saying
this is only the beginning you'll start
to see all these crazy stories coming
out of existence in the dark multiverse
because there's so much to be explored
it maybe there's somebody out there
worse than Barbados but in the midst of
this battle the flash Barry Allen races
in grabs Superman and takes off and the
reason why is because they basically
bring him to a place called the oblivion
bar now a little bit of history here
with Marvel becoming such a huge
competitor to DC in the 1960s with like
Thor and the return of Captain America
spider-man the x-men Fantastic Four
there was basically like this great gold
rush of superheroes that was coming out
of the comic book industries one of
reasons why people say the 1970s running
up to the 1990s for that 20 year span
was one of the most prolific or as in
comic books because publishers were just
cranking out superheroes and comics all
over the place but back in 1969 with who
is DC showcase number 82 a guy by the
name of Jim rook was created the general
idea is that he was one of the
characters that sort of fell in line
with the Constantine swampthing esque
line of stories in the sense they didn't
really crossover with a lot of major
superheroes instead he was part of that
darker mystic magic basically the
predecessor to what would become vertigo
later on down the line in his journeys
he had stumbled across a place called
the oblivion bark and the oblivion bar
was just kind of this place where
different people would go to and they
were part of the whole you know like
Constantine different things like that
they would show up to that whole
location but it's basically one of the
last safe places in existence the
problem with this is that in rescuing
Superman while all these members who had
fought the dark nights and the origin
stories of the dark nights when all
those characters were being whisked away
by dr. faith at the end of the
this is where they were coming to but
because of the fact that they basically
grabbed Superman and brought him here in
the midst of his battle with the Dark
Knight's while it was being observed by
Barbados what they've effectively done
is left a magic based bread crab red
crumb trail and it was only a matter of
time before they find out where they're
at and they've got minutes before the
dark Knights get there and all things
begin to go into pandemonium and so what
is up happening is we get this sort of
quick rundown of the things that have
been going on in the sense that you know
the murder machine basically sent all
these different versions of Alfred to
Detroit these you know machine based
Alfred's of course we read about that in
the origin story we read about how Red
Death had basically initiated a Speed
Force storm that kills everybody who
comes into contact with it that in all
these origin stories when the dark these
dark nights were popping up in the
respective cities where they showed up
they've basically been conquered what we
also end up finding out though is that
from Green Arrow in metal harms these
various members of the Dark Knights it's
their equivalent of kryptonite and the
only way to really defeat them is to use
info metal but as we've covered in metal
is just one of those very rare materials
that exists out there and there's almost
none of it left and so what they need is
not just in metal but basically any of
the metals that were used to bomb to
Batman to send him to the dark
multiverse so it basically turns into
this idea where it's the hunt for in
metal alongside these other metals that
are out there the problem is that while
this is going on you also have dr. fate
you have you a mr. terrific classic man
who's still in an egg you have a lot of
these superheroes who really haven't
been seen in the new 52 that DC is only
now bringing back in DC rebirth
analyzing all these things out there and
saying okay here's locations we can go
to to find these different aspects of
these different metals but one thing I
want you to notice is that the location
of one of these metals is in the center
of the multiverse also known as the rock
of eternity now those are the guys who
know about the rock of eternity I'm sure
you're just like yes the rock of
eternity like one of the things being at
the rock of eternity is a big deal
because the person who resides at the
rock of eternity is Shazam and we have
no idea where Shazam is we don't I mean
we know he was in like the Constantine
book but that was it we've seen neither
hide nor hair of him since
really since DC rebirth showed up and so
this seems to indicate the idea that
even if it's only a cameo we may have
Shazam in the Dark Knight's metal book
what this does is it invokes the idea
that the metals that they're hunting for
are not just earth base
fight the story largely focusing on in
metal and its involvement on the planet
Earth if metal stretches across the
cosmos and there's a huge chunk of intha
metal that resides within the dark
multiverse now the indication seems to
be here that Carter Hall basically
Hawkman the being that set all this
stuff in motion in the first place
most likely he's being held in the dark
multiverse and the instumental is with
him we're not 100% sure but the other
speculation offered by the superheroes
is that Batman has that in metal on him
and so that man has it as a means once
he's able to escape the control of
Barbados to use it against the Dark
Knight this is when Superman begins to
step up Superman's rationale is that man
needs to be saved and Batman's asking to
be saved the reason why he says this is
because in that dream Superman was
having when Batman said carpe diem
there was a reason behind it within DC
Comics while it is currently a title at
the moment and it has been in the past
you basically have what's called the
Trinity Batman Superman and Wonder Woman
the three most popular characters in DC
Comics for the most part the idea is
that with the three of them being the
Trinity there was basically a sort of
code that was set up between the three
of them in order to ensure that if any
of them was in danger they could call
for aid in the case of Batman it was
Clark Diana CD and the case of Wonder
Woman it was Batman and Clark he was BC
that was the pattern that they used when
Batman made the statement
carpe diem it wasn't saying carpe diem
it was saying C D Clark Diana come and
help me it was Batman calling for aid
Superman basically says Batman's calling
for our help Batman's being held there
we have to get to the Dark multiverse we
have to save him if we do then
everything will be fine but in the
middle of all that of course one of the
little Robins of the Batman who last
shows up and he's immediately taken out
by a dagger of sorts only for us to find
out the person who threw it is
Deathstroke and that's cool because this
basically Deathstroke being rolled in to
this whole thing now I firmly believe
this is being done just because the
Justice League movie but you know
Deathstroke in terms of his role in the
the greater the greater pantheon of
things it actually makes sense because
Deathstroke has for years used armor and
weapons made out of promethium it's a
hallmark of his character promethium is
one of the metals that was bonded to
Batman to send him to the dark
multiverse and so much like a tuning
fork of sorts or to magnets you know
they're basically pulled together
promethium can offer itself as sort of a
tracking device to figure out these
different metals that exist out there
so what they end up doing is splitting
into groups going to Atlantis going to
middle of space the rock of eternity but
before they do
Superman grabs the flash and they race
off to the fortress of solitude because
one of the things that flash makes a
comment on and really even one of the
things that steel makes it comment on is
the Tower of the anti-monitor
this holtzhauer basically made its
appearance and the events of Infinite
Crisis
now when the new 52 first started in
2011 Infinite Crisis was wiped away had
technically never happened what this
does is it says actually it did that the
heroes remember Infinite Crisis they
remember all those events taking place
and so it's kind of cool moreso than
that Superman has this really
interesting plan with regards to how to
get to the dark multiverse if we use the
Grand Canyon as an example on one side
is Superman on the other side is the
dark multiverse in the middle of the
Grand Canyon
is the Phantom Zone basically this
massive prison that people are sent into
whenever it is they're imprisoned by
Kryptonians historically the question is
how do we create a bridge that gets us
through the Phantom Zone and to the
other side with the dark multiverses now
in my mind because of the fact that the
dark multiverse is on the opposite side
of the positive multiverse I would say
it's not just the Phantom Zone in that
huge canyon so to speak that you
basically got the edge of the multiverse
maybe even the edge of the source wall I
have no earthly clue what's there but I
would say is probably more than just the
Phantom Zone but even if it is what it
basically means is the Phantom Zone is
not just this endless void that's out
there instead of the Phantom Zone is a
finite space is basically a giant room
more or less where people are housed
it's not an endless expanse of a
dimension or anything along those lines
so it's kind of cool
Superman's argument is if we're able to
use the Speed Force in conjunction with
this giant tower that basically emits
these different frequencies it'll allow
us to vibrate through the multiverse
then what you can do is supercharge
using your Speed Force and allow me to
punch through and that's cool because
that's exactly what happens Superman
basically races through you know steel
using his energy signatures to basically
just start amping up the Tower of the
anti-monitor flash using the Speed Force
to supercharge Superman and sending him
through there basically meaning that for
a moment in time Superman gets the
powers of the flash but Superman
basically punching through and getting
to the dark multiverse what we end up
finding out is exactly what we expected
this was a track it was never designed
to actually allow Superman to rescue
Batman instead of running into all these
Dark Knight's what he runs into
or all these evil versions of himself
these evil versions of Superman that
exists out there what ends up happening
is Batman says I warned you not to come
here when the song was played at the
beginning of the story with our sons
playing that rock band
you heard CD the actual song was DC
don't come here and so it was awesome
because it's basically Batman who sent a
code to Superman saying look do not come
to this place do not come here it's a
trap the reason why is because Superman
is a living solar battery he's the
source of energy that they need to allow
the dark nights to sort of open up this
dark energy portal and literally
engulfed the multiverse and darkness in
essence and Superman's rush to save the
life of Batman he's doomed the
multiverse in DC Comics with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob core you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]